[Musica]
vi racconto due storie la prima riguarda
matilde di canossa
la gran contessa che tutti conosciamo
per il perdono di canossa ma di qui
forse non sappiamo certi aspetti che
l'hanno resa una donna eccezionale che è
stata perché dico eccezionale
perché lei ha avuto il coraggio di
accettare quello che la vita le chiedeva
anche se priva
inaccettabile
perché in pieno medioevo si è ritrovata
a governare un territorio vasto come
mezza italia perché è stata la sola
persona
capace di imporsi tra papa e imperatore
come mediatrice tra papy imperatore
durante la guerra per le investiture
perché è stata prima indica donna ha
sede il campo di battaglia ea combattere
al fianco dei suoi tornati e infine
perché fa tutto questo per una donna nel
medioevo era impossibile
allora perché lei l'ha fatto se è
impossibile
perché ha avuto il coraggio di accettare
il suo destino
non siete borse non si è fermata agli
schemi femminili della sua epoca ma li
ha superati per il bene del suo popolo e
per i suoi ideali
in realtà
lei avrebbe voluto andare in convento
falsi monaca
bellavita
decise diversamente non le lascia scelta
perché il padre
morì in un'imboscata
i fratelli morirono avvelenati
dall'imperatore così rimase solo a lei
il compito di guidare un territorio
vastissimo e in seguito di dover
decidere da che parte sta è tra papy
imperatore cosa non semplice
in questo modo
accettando il suo destino matilde ha
compiuti imprese eccezionali ed è
diventata l'eroina femminile del
medioevo
la seconda storia che quanta eleonora
tempo vera la principessa salda nata nel
vissuta nel 1300 e in sardegna
e la figlia del giudice maiano che
allora governava il giudicati del
governo sottoposto a vedi catalogna
pietro
baiano notò per renderlo indipendente
quando morì il governo passo al figlio
ugo
ed eleonora dopo lunga attesa aveva
finalmente sposato noia e sia passata
genova
allora voi
vi chiederete cosa avrà mai fatto questa
eleonora in effetti la sua vita sarebbe
dovuta trascorre così diceva tranquilla
a fare sono la moglie la madre
ma anche per lei il destino che mi serve
qualcos'altro
il fratello fu ucciso insieme alla
figlia e i nomi di star di chiesero
elonora di reggio è giudicato lei
accettò la sfida torna in sardegna
acclamata con ogni onore
prese possesso delle terre e continuo
l'opera del padre
fu l'unica donna la prima e unica donna
reggere un giudicato e adem è un codice
di leggi
comunque infatti la carta de logu
che insieme alle altre norme dava
particolare spazio alla tutela delle
donne specialmente quelle vittime di
stupro
non so se lo sapete ma le donne stuprate
nel medioevo si suicidavano perché non
avevano possibilità di futuro
eleonora diede loro l'opportunità di
vivere dignitosamente
obbligando l'uomo che l'aveva violata
sposai oppure a mantenerle per la vita
inoltre questo codice di leggi era
scritto in lingua salda volgar invece
che il latino affinché tutti potessero
comprenderlo
idea così innovativo che i muse e che in
base valido fino al 1827 fino
all'entrata in vigore del codice
albertino in questo modo e lo ha
lasciato segno nella storia è stata una
donna eccezionale avendo conti per gli
schemi femminili della società
dell'epoca
anche noi come
come come
le nostre due rovine possiamo avere per
il nostro futuro dei sogni piccoli o
grandi che siano ma a volte il destino
ci chiede di abbandonare per realizzare
qualcosa che non era nei nostri cani
come queste due donne che hanno
accettato ciò che il destino aveva aveva
in serbo per loro
aveva in serbo per loro e si sono
dedicate alla loro missione con tutte se
stesse la vita è un dono prezioso
limitarsi a sopravvivere sarebbe perdere
un'opportunità per realizzare con sé
grandi
come vede come vedete
io sono disabile
non lo sono sempre stata almeno non così
e anch'io come matilde la nuova aviv
miei sogni
volevo essere autonoma camminare ma
anche per me il destino aveva in serbo
qualcos'altro e non fu facile la
serranda e questi sogni che erano tanti
importanti
inoltre quand'ero piccola tutti mi
diceva che siccome ero sulla carrozzina
non avrei mai potuto realizzare nulla
che tutto mi era per caso che ho
impossibilitata ad aggiungerci agli
obiettivi
la fisioterapista
mi diceva che come lavorava e tatto la
centralinista
i professori delle medie mi dicevano che
non avrei mai potuto frequentare il
liceo classico perché nessun disabile
aveva mai fatto prima
io mi chiedevo perché
perché penso l'ho fatto di esser sedia a
rotelle non potevo fare nulla
questo era lo schema di vita che mi
veniva proprio che mi veniva proposto e
non mi stava bene perché io volevo
qualcosa di più come le donne che ho
citato che non hanno subito un destino
diverso dai loro sogni ballo anni
incarnato e nessuno diventate
protagoniste
dimostrando ciò che veramente
così con determinazione ho frequentato
il liceo classico mi sono laureata io
sono una scrittrice
come ho fatto
prima
ho dovuto accettare la mia condizione
l'accettazione
della realtà
delle condizioni della condizione della
propria vita è qualcosa di
indispensabile per andare oltre e
superare quel che all'inizio sembrano
ostacoli ma che poi
che abbiano possono rivelarsi
opportunità
io ci sono riuscita grazie alla mia fede
in dio ma anche chi non crede può farlo
è difficile
difficile ma si può cambiare prospettiva
e vedere la situazione in modo diverso
segui fosse limitata a vedere la
carrozzina la mia condizione la
carrozzina in particolare come qualcosa
come sono solo con una limitazione che
mi avrebbe impedito di vivere
dignitosamente
non sarei qui oggi
cambia prospettiva ci porta a dire a noi
stessi
sono in questa situazione non mi piace
non è quello che vorrei ma non la posso
cambiare e allora cosa posso fare per
cercare di vivere la vita in modo
migliore
ho scelto di di imitare le due donne di
cui vi ho parlato sono andata oltre gli
schemi sociali per realizzare un futuro
migliore quello che credevo più giusto e
adatto per me anche se tutti mi dicevano
è impossibile
io non ho chiavi o ricette da dare mi
piacerebbe ma non le
chiavi o ricette da dare per di
raggiungere impossibile
in qua perché per ognuno c'è una strada
diversa
un percorso tutto personale per arrivare
alla meta
la chiave che ho trovato è efficace
anche per me
e stato qui è stata quella adottata
dalle due eroine
crede che proprio lì dove siamo chiamati
a stare a vivere nonostante le nostre i
belloni iniziale che si può vedere
impossibile perciò pensa quello che vuoi
fare per il tuo futuro nel tuo futuro
anche se per vari motivi ti dicono ma è
impossibile
e chiediti
davvero impossibile
[Applauso]
[Musica]